there's a debate that grime is dead some
people say
would you agree with that statement no i
don't agree that graham's dead no no
it's not going to be dead some people
just lazy
they just they just say [ __ ] for the
sake of saying [ __ ] like they say they
said that about
jungle they say they say about they said
hip-hop's dead
a few years ago nah's made it cool this
album hip-hop's dead
hip-hop ain't dead like not like nothing
really dies does it it's not
it's not dead just it's not at the
forefront right now of the pop charts
but it didn't start at the forefront of
the pop charts oh
if you're talking about um in the gram
scene who's
not even necessarily up and coming back
but flying the flag
for graham i'd say jme
p money those are the guys i know that
that's that this
jamie called his album grammy mc so i
don't know what more you wanted
yeah that's that in it i spoke to a kid
um
meeks from manny from manchester meets
manny
i think he's a like incredible lyricist
like he's
very vivid very sharp with his words and
his imagery his videos are crazy as well
i like that especially where he
could be starting from the bottom and
i think that guy's going places